nos dicen el polinomio de x es igual a x
kubica más 9 que es cuadrada menos 108 y
tiene como factor a x 6 reescribe apede
x como el producto de factores lineales
bien pausa el vídeo e intenta encontrar
la respuesta
muy bien vamos a trabajar juntos debido
a que nos dan uno de los factores lo que
podemos hacer es pensar en qué sucederá
si dividimos apt x / x 6 que me queda
bueno parece que obtendré una expresión
cuadrática y probablemente pueda
factorizar la para encontrar los
factores lineales de px así que manos a
la obra queremos encontrar el resultado
de x + 6 que divide a x cúbica más 9 x
cuadrada y ahora hay que tener cuidado
tal vez estemos tentados a escribir a un
lado menos 108 como lo hice pero esto
tiene un cierto orden porque tenemos la
columna de los términos de tercer grado
la columna de los términos de segundo
grado y necesitamos la columna de los
términos de primer grado y después la
columna de los términos constantes o de
grado cero así que para asegurarnos de
que vamos a tener
y saludable voy a agregar más 0 x y te
pido que siempre hagas esto cuando estés
escribiendo un polinomio y no te saltes
este lugar y por último menos 108
y después decidimos vamos a ver los
términos con grado mayor x cabe en x
cúbica x cuadrada a veces por lo tanto x
cuadrada x 66 x cuadrada y x cuadrada x
x x kubica queremos restar esto lo hemos
hecho varias veces hace que mire un poco
más rápido de lo normal estas se
cancelan y me queda que 9 x cuadrada
menos 6 x cuadrada es lo mismo que 3 x
cuadrada bajamos el 0 x y luego cuántas
veces cabe x en 3x cuadrada bueno cabe
3x entonces lo escribiré en esta columna
observa si nos hubiéramos saltado esta
columna de términos de primer grado
estaríamos un poco confundido sobre todo
de escribir el 3x en la parte de arriba
pero ahora ya lo tenemos y nos quedan 3x
por 6 es 18 x y 3 x por x es 3x cuadrada
pero queremos restar así que cambiamos
los signos estos dos se cancelan y
después tengo 0 x menos 18 x de lo cual
obtenemos menos 18 x y bajamos el menos
y por último x cabe en menos 18 x menos
18 veces me queda menos 18 por 6 es
menos 108 parece que todo va quedando
perfecto y menos 18 por x es menos 18 x
y como queremos restar tenemos que
cambiar el signo a todo es decir
multiplicar por menos 1 y observa todo
se cancela así obtengo un residuo de 0
por lo tanto puedo reescribirá pd x como
x 6 que multiplica a x cuadrada más 3 x
menos 18 pero todavía no hemos terminado
ya que esto no es un término lineal
sigue siendo cuadrática ahora necesito
pensar en dos números que al sumar se me
den 3 y que al multiplicarse entre sí
mete en menos 18 bueno son dos números
con signos distintos y los que me
parecen más obvios son seis positivos y
tres negativos
y si lo que acabo de hacer parece vudú
para ti te encargo que veas el tema de
factorizar polinomios en khan academy
entonces como más 6 y menos 3 la suma me
that 3 y 6 x menos 3 es menos 18
entonces puedo escribir esto como un x6
ok esto que multiplica a x 6 que su vez
multiplica a x 3 y ya lo tenemos aquí
está escrito pd x como el producto de
factores lineales con esto hemos
terminado